Speaker 1: We got a ton of voicemails yesterday
about my interview with Mypillow CEO Mike Lindell.
I have to tell you, I struggled with how to
conduct that interview because he's so shot
out of a cannon and all over the place. And a lot
of people criticized my handling of the interview.
Here's one caller who thought that I did okay.
Speaker 3: Hi, David. This is Bonnie from Utah.
I just wanted to tell you that I really
enjoyed your conversation with my pillow.
I was actually quite impressed with him. He didn't
seem quite as, shall we say, anxious and sweaty,
as he sometimes does. So maybe he
switched to decaf. Who knows? Maybe.
I was impressed with your interaction with him
and your degree of respect and your ability
to really in the conversation when he sort of
was trying to jump out of the corral. Yeah. So
good job. I enjoy your program. And I'm a 65
year old liberal progressive broad from Utah.
So, yeah, it is a challenge, but keep
up the good work. You're doing great.
Speaker 1: Well, I really appreciate that. There
were positive comments and negative comments about
the interview. There were people who wrote and
said, I didn't interrupt enough. There were people
who wrote and said, I interrupted too much, etc.,
etc.. I do the best I can and I think it went
okay and generating it now. By the way, he did say
many things that weren't true. Like, for example,
one of the things pillows are obviously one of the
things he said was none of the judges that threw
out election challenges threw them out on merits,
only on standing. Within minutes of the interview
posting, someone emailed me a judge in Wisconsin
who threw out a case based on the merits. So it's
it can be difficult to have all the information
handy as the interview was going on. And that's
one of the big challenges. Sam Harris, whatever
you think about, Sam Harris accurately describes
the difficulty with these interviews where he
says someone, you can only be so prepared. They
can always find something you're not familiar
with. They show up and they make some statement
about it. They said a bunch of small fires and now
you have to figure out how to put each fire out.
And it can be very difficult. And that certainly
was a factor yesterday. We've got a great bonus
show for you today. Producer Pat is back no longer
under the weather. We will talk about new concerns
about a papal draft leak. We will talk about the
Uvalde Uvalde de Uvalde School District suspending
its entire police department. We will talk about
the latest on self-driving cars, which I think
you will find interesting and much more. Get the
bonus show by signing up at join pacman dot com.